في انتظاري حسما للسيطره على الكونجرس
بمجلسيه تظهر نتائج الاوليه في الانتخابات
النصفيه الامريكيه ان الجمهوريين لم
يحققوا الفوز الكاسح الذي توقعته
استطلاعاته الراي وتقدم الجمهوريون على
ديمقراطيين في مجلس النواب لكن ايا من
الحزبين لم يحقق الاغلبيه حتى اللحظه اما
في مجلس الشيوخ فاستطاع الحزب ديمقراطي
وحصد مقعد اضافي بينما تبقى الاغلبيه فيه
معلقه مع تواصل الفرس
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام الى برنامج ما
وراء الخبر القديم
بحسب النتائج الاوليه للانتخابات النصفيه
فان الجمهوريين يتقدمون على ديموقراطيين
في مجلس النواب بينما ينتظر الحزبان
الفراغ من فرز اصوات الناخبين في ولايات
امريكيا من اجل حسم السيطره على الاغلبيه
بمجلس الشيوخ يذكر ان تامينها الاغلبيه في
مجلس النواب يتطلب الحصول على 2008
ويحتاج الجمهوريون الى الفوز بواحد 51
مقعدا لضمان الاغلبيه في مجلس الشيوخ
المؤلف من مئات بينما يكفي الديمقراطيين
الحصول على 50 مقعدا والاعتماد على الصوت
المنجح الى ابره الرئيس من اجل الاغلبيه
للمزيد ينضم الينا جول روبن محلل الجزيره
لشؤون الانتخابات النصفيه والمساعد السابق
لوزير الخارجيه الامريكي ومعنا في
الاستوديو ايضا هنا في واشنطن نارينج محلل
الجزيره لشؤون الانتخابات والقيادي في
الحزب الجمهوري مرحبا بكما سنبدا معكم
هل يمكن القول ان الجمهوريين اخفقوا في
التحقيق الموجه الحمراء
بانها ستتحقق
حمراء
في الوقت نفسه الجمهوريون اكيدون من
السيطره على مجلس النواب حين يفقد احد
الاحزاب الحاكمه سيطر على احد المجلسين
فهذا خساره ولكن بالنسبه الى الجمهوريين
هو فوز اقل من مكان يجب ان يكون عليه
بالنظر طبعا الى ظروف الاقتصاديه مدى
تدهور شعبيه
الجمهوريين ان يتدارسوا داخليا ما حصل
واين
تكمن الهواتف
تكرارها في المستقبل
هذا ما نتحدث عنه سنتحدث عنه في هذه
الحلقه ولكن جو قبل ااا كل ذلك كيف يقيم
الديمقراطيون النتيجه حتى الان باعتقادك
بما ثابت بعض الترددات الحمراء
الديمقراطيون يشعرون بالقوه اليوم كان
بيضا قد اظهر انه يجب ان يكون المرشح
الرئاسي بعد سنتين
الجمهوريون اوضحوا للشعب الامريكي انهم
ليسوا ملائمين للقياده حتى في عدد من
السباقات الانتخابيه الخاصه بحكام
الولايات في مسلسل
الامور تبدو جيدا لديموقراطيين هذه سباقات
الانتخابيه التي خرج النخبون للتصويت فيها
وتوحد فيها الديمقراطيون
ونرى ان هذا الانتخابات كانت لصالح
الديمقراطين وليس للجمهوريه
اذا ان هذا فوز كبير الديمقراطيين صحيح ان
مجلس النواب سيكون تحت السيطره جمهوريه
ومعي سيصعب الامر على بيضه
على مجلس الشي خوخه همم مع همم موضوع همم
جورجيا حيث يجب ان ننتظر لنرى ان نتائج
وهذا امر يجب ان او يفخر به حاليا
رغم ما قلته وما قاله
الجمهوريين يتجهون على الاقل حتى الان
للسيطره على مجلس النواب
وفرنسي
الحالي
الفوز فان الحسبه المعارض يجب ان يفوز ب
40 الى 60
ما راينا هو ان هذا الانجازات الديمقراطيه
هي التي جعلتنا نفوز في عدد من الحالات
قدنا في عدد من المقاعد
لالاسيه ما في ما يتعلق همم مرشحين شباب
مثلا موضوع تغير مناخيه موضوع تخفيض وحتى
اعفاء طلاب من الطيور حقوق المراه كل هذا
كانت عوامل محافظه راينا ذلك في استطلاعات
رائعه حتى في كانتي
بوشن باريس
حقوق الاجهاض وقد سقط ذلك اذا قضايا كثيره
فاز على اساسها الديمقراطيون الناخبون لم
يقتنعوا بقضايا الجمهوريين وكان يجب ان
يكون ذلك امرا يثير الوعي لدى الجمهوريين
ولكنهم لم يعوا
رانيا البلاغ الجمهوريون باعتقادك في
الاعتماد وفي الدفع بشعار الاقتصاد في هذه
الانتخابات على حساب شعارات اخرى ليست اقل
اهميه بالنسبه للامريكيين
بحبك بحبك
مع ان الاقتصاد ليس جيدا وبايتا ليس ذا
شعبيه عاليه تضخم جرائم كثر من الناخبين
برغم من ذلك انتخب وجوه انتخبوا
ديمقراطيين
ماذا عن رسائل التي نبعث بها ما هي
الحملات التي نقودها وما هو تعريف الحزب
الجمهوري هذا كله يجب ان يفكر فيه ونعيد
النظر فيه انت اذا طريرت الى الخروج من
بيتك لتنامى علي في الشارع لم تقول ان
يومك كان ممتازا بعكس الديمقراطيين هم
خرجوا من احد المجلسين او فقدوا السيطره
عليه هو برغم من ذلك يسرون على القول نحن
نقدم اداء ممتازه هم يلعبون لعبه التوقعات
كان يجب على الجمهوريه ان يحققوا فوزا كبر
ومن المخيب الا يكون قد حققه ذلك ولكن
بالرغم من ذلك اديموقراطيون فقط
مع انه ليس الفوز التي توقعناه ولكنه ليس
فوزا الديمقراطيين
في نفس السياقه التي تتحدث به رن الان يتم
الحديث عن ربما اسوء اداء للحزب الجمهوري
في هذه الظروف الحاليه يعني حزب ليس في
السلطه في انتخابات نصفيه مع استطلاعات
راي مخيبه للرئيس الحالي ما الذي حصل
لماذا
الجمهوريه للانتخابات لعلاقه بالمستقبل
وليس بالماضي الرئيس ترامب اراد السابق
طبعا ترامب اراد ان يركز على الماضي وان
يحجج مره اخرى حول موضوع انتخابات 2010
سيء هناك امثله اخرى لمرشحين دعامهم
الرئيس ترامب
الله اكبر لاي سبب كان ولكنهم لم يكنوا
الاقوى في نيو هامشر وغيرها اذا الحزب
الجمهوري يجب ان يعيد تعريف نفسه على انه
حزب المستقبل وليس الماضي وان يختار مرشحا
مرشحين افضل ليس معرضين للخساره هاتان
النقطتان الاساسيه اللتان ادتها الى خساره
اقل بكثير او الى فوزا اقل بكثير مما
توقعنا اجمل هو انا فلوس لن تعود رئيسه
مجلس النواب
ولكن ماذا تقول
لشخصيات مهمه في باريس في همم
تراجع لك في ارزونا خسارات لشخصيات اا
اساسيه دعمها ترامب مقابل فوز لشخصيات في
داخل الحزب الجمهوري لم يدعمها ترامب ماذا
يقول لنا هذا الامر
اوفراو
ما في سباقات 30
الاقوى ولم يقوم بحملات واضحه مهيكله
لتركز على المستقبل
قاموا بتعليقات اسرع مواقف كانت مثيره
للجدل اذا وصفناها بافضل طريقه وهذا لوث
قد فرسه في النجاح
في النهايه الولايات المتحده هي تعتمد
النظام على اساس المرشحين وليس على اساس
الحزم المرشح يطلع بدور اكبر مما يلعبه
مثلا المرشح في الانتخابات في اوروبا
الاساس في هذه السباقات الى مجلس الشيوخ
هو ان يكون شخصا محبوبا من قبل الناخبين
من قبل غالبيه وليس من قبل زملائه داخل
الحزب
في خلال الحملات الانتخابيه جون كان
الديمقراطيون يطلبون من الجمهوريين برفض
هذا هذه الخطوات التي تقدم بها بعض ابرز
المرشحين الذين خسروا الانتخابات وكانوا
مدعومين من ترامب هل بخسارتهم يقدم
لديمقراطيين الجواب
للناخبين ان هؤلاء المرشحين يقولون اشياء
غير مقبوله
بالنسبه الى مصر
او بالنسبه الى منصب الحاكم تحدث عن
السادس من يناير المشكله بالنسبه الى
الحزب الجمهوري في المستقبل هو انهم
المرشحون الشعبيون لدى الناخبين
الجمهوريين ولكن احدا لم يعطيهم هذه هذا
الترشيحهم همم عملوا عليه جاهدين دعمهم
ترامب وهم فازوا في الانتخابات الاوليه
هذا لن يختفي ولا سيختفي ترامب ترامب
يختفي لديه سبب وجودي للاستمرار بالفرشه
هذا يعني انه بالنسبه للجمهوريين ليس
لديهم اجوبه وحلول التعامل مع الواقع يجب
ان يقدموا اذا عن مرشحين محبوبين لا
يبعدون ولا ينفرون الناخبين الامريكيين
رونالدو كيف باعتقادك سيتعامل الحزب
الجمهوري مع هذه النتيجه وكيف ستنعكس على
الحزب وعلى بعض ابرز القيادات فيه
والاجنحه في داخله
سؤال
هذه الانتخابات سوف يحصل مباشره الان
حين يبدا السباق الانتخابي الرئاسيه
المحموم يمكننا ان نراهن ان لائحه من
المرشحين الذين يريدون الترشح للانتخابات
الرئاسيه يحللون ما حصل يعيدون حساباتهم
في الوقت نفسه
منذ 30 عاما حين تحصل الخساره تقدم حجه
مهمه لان احدا لا يريد الاعتراف بسوق
قراره وبالتالي نحن بحاجه لنظره موضوعيه
من الصعب ان يحققها وادي عمليات طويله
داخليه وتامل داخلي
سيكون لدينا مرشحون جمهوريون مثل الروند
سانتوس الذي كان فائزا كبيرا في الامس
اعتقد ان ترامب على المستوى الوطني هو
اكبر الخاسرين لانه عليه ان يمتصل كثير من
هذه الخسا الجمهوريه لكن
ساحقا في ولايه كانت انتخب ديمقراطيين ولا
انصار جمهوريه
هذه هي الجدالات التي سوف تحصل الان حين
يحاول حيث ان يعيد تعريف نفسه وتكوين
هويته
الانتخابات الاتيه سوف تعتمد على المرشحين
الرئاسيين وليس مرشحين الكونجرس
يعتبر في موقف اقوى بكثير بعكس ترامب الذي
صار اضعف بكثير ما كان عليه منذ 24 ساعه
لكن جوا قال لنا قبل قليل ترامب لن يعترف
بذلك هل تعتقد ان هذا ما سيحدث
الجمهوري الناخبون جمهوري سيفعلون فراندو
سانتوس يحضر بالكثير من الدعم بما فيه
اشخاص كانوا يدعمون ترامب في 2020 وقبل
والجو الاثار عددا من الاسئله المهمه لكن
في نهايه المطاف الثالث من يناير في ذلك
المبنى
سيكون رئيس مجلس النواب وليست
مع انه صغير لكنه الفوز
هذا مهم جدا بالنسبه لك على كل
روبن ايضا يعني ما يقوله رن صحيح ان
الجمهوريين بالنهايه سيطروا على مجلس
النواب صحيح ان هذا يحدث دائما ااه في
معظم الاحيان في الانتخابات النصفيه ولكن
ايضا ترافق ذلك مع ارقام مخيبه للرئيس
الامريكي كيف باعتقادك سيتعامل الحزب
الديمقراطي مع هذه النتيجه
باي باي
سنتين سوف يستعيد الديمقراطيون مجلس
النواب الجمهوريه كانوا بحاجه الى هامشان
كبير في 2018 كان هناك انتخابات سيطرنا
فيها على 40 في 2020 قبل ذلك لكننا بقينا
مسيحصل هو انا القياده الجمهوريه سوف تبدا
اوروبا
سوف يكون لديه قاعده غير منضبطه سوف تجعل
حياته بائسه على الارجح سيكون هناك مجلس
الشيوخ ديمقراطي والان هناك حزب الديمقرا
موحد يدعم بعيدا هذه الاسئله حول ما اذا
كان سترشح ام لا هذا قد حسيمه
هذا امر مهم وسوف يمكن الرئيس ان يختار
الجمهوريين لانهم سوف يخشون على استمراريه
وبقائهم وبالتاليهم ليسوا في موقفا قوي في
كافه الهيل بالرغم من سيطرهم على احد
المجلسين
يعني نسب متدنيه جدا لاداء الجو باردن 70%
من الامريكيين قالوا انهم لا يؤيدون ان
يترشح بايضا في الانتخابات المقبله هذا
كله كيف يترجم في داخل الحزب الديمقراطي
وماذا عن ايضا الخاسرون والربحون اليوم في
داخل الحزب على غرار ما يحدث في داخل
الحزب الجمهوري
انا
اخطات مره اخرى
الكثير من الاستطلاعات لم تغطي هذا الجيل
الحديث الذي انتخب ديمقراطيين هم لا
يجيبون اصلا على استطلاعات الراي اجابه
على سؤالك حول الخسائر والفوز كانت ان
نتائج مختلطه ومن الصعب ان نعمر مثلا كان
هناك ثلاثه سباقات محمومه لديمقراطيين
اثنان من السباقات حصلت في طريقه التنفسيه
كبيره كان هناك خسائر كبيره
وحساس على ديمقراطيين ان يقلق بشانها لكن
لا اعتقد ان هناك شعور عام الان بان مواقف
الرئيس وهي غير شعبيه كما ظهر في الصلعات
الراي والتعليقات بالنسبه للانتخابات
الرئاسيه في 2020 هناك نقطه مهمه وحساسه
لها علاقه
بالمدواس الوسط الغربي
الان مع حكام واعضاء مجلس شيوخ وحكام او
سكرتاير ولايات بالاحرى هي صارت ولايات
زرقاء ديموقراطيه ربما نخسر فلوريدا
خسرناها من قبل
ان يحصل على فلوريدا الا انت عوده
ديمقراطيه عن قريب لكن هذا الجدار الازرق
سارق قويا وهذا اساس قوه
ديمقراطيين يتطلعون على هذا نوع من
الديناميكيات ل همم يبعثوا برسائلهم
يعملوا مع هذه المجتمعات في الولايات
الصناعيه اذا مجلس الشيوخ
يقترح القوانين وسيكون على الجمهوريين
التعامل مع ذلك
دعني اشيل الى هذا الخبر العاجل جول ورون
يبدو ان المرشح الجمهوري في ولايه وسكنسل
رون جونسون فاز على منزله بونز المرشح
الديمقراطي وهذا يحيل الى ان المقاعد التي
ذهبت في مجلس الشيوخ الى الجمهوريين تصبح
49 بينما 48 مقعدا هي من نصيب
الديمقراطيين حتى الان همم
يقول لنا همم جول بالفعل ستكون المطرقه
معك هذا المكارسي ولكن هناك قاعده مشتته
ولم تكون هذه المطرقه قويه كما ذكر ما
رايك بهذا الكلام
كويسين
لكن برغم من ذلك هناك الكثير من المشاكل
على الجانب الديمقراطي دعونا لا نكذب على
بعضنا 65% من الامريكيين يرفضون ترشح
بايدا في 2014
اعضاء الكونغرس الذين قتلوا قبل شهر مثلا
هذه الاخطاء هذا كله سيظهر ان بعيدا ليس
قادرا على
ان يكون رئيسا لست سنوات اضافيه سياسه
الامريكيه ليست سوداء او بيضاء هي معقده
من الجانبين
اريد ان اسالك ما هي الاجنده ما الذي
يتصدر اجندت الجمهوريين الان في مجلس
النواب
[موسيقى]
نفس نفسنا فيها اغلى الحمله التضخم
والاقتصاد ومعادل جرائم والطاقه كل هذه
القضايا في الوقت نفسه
سوف نركز على الرقابه الاداريه رقم على
الاداره بالاحرى التحقيق في كيفيه التعامل
اداره الرئيس بعيدا وعدن مع القضايا من
القضايا عفوا من هذا من هذا المنظور كل
ذلك يرتبط بما يريد بعيدا تحقيقه من قبل
لم يكن عليه ان يقوم باي تنازلات الان
عليه ان يقوم بها
ينعكس هذا هذه النتيجه على بقيه رئاسه
باختصار
باريس
الابيض الجزيره
[موسيقى]